( rock music playing )
Well, in the shots,
your arm is incredibly flappy.
The flesh is all over the place.
So we should get
a lovely close-up of that.
That would be awesome.
Yeah, let's do it.
Dan: Oh, man.
Gav: Oh, my goodness.
And the fingers.
Love the fingers there.
And all of your fingers
were all over.
Your whole arm just twists.
( overlapping chatter,
giggling )
Have you ever tried
the stone-faced one?
Just like,
"I'm not bothered."
Yeah. Yeah, I can't do it.
All right, lads,
follow me up here.
Your mark is made
of celery.
Celery markers.
And this highly scientific board
with some feet drawn on it.
Are we going to be able to see
the speed that we're throwing at
by measuring the--
Yeah. We'll just be able to see
who's faster than you.
- Okay.
- All right.
Try and get this melon
as well, shall we?
All right, I'll count you in.
I'll do three, two, one, throw.
- Okay.
- Ready?
Three, two, one, throw.
- Yeah.
- That was good.
Three, two, one, throw.
Gav:
Okay, who was fastest?
Dan: I wonder how much faster
you were?
Gav: So we got the thing up here
so we can measure the speed.
Dan: Thing is I didn't even
throw it that good.
( overlapping chatter )
Rick: No, you did really well.
Dan: Whoo.
- Gav: Incredibly clean.
- Dan: Wow.
Gav: I love that.
It's such a satisfying moment.
( rock music playing )
Hello again.
We're gonna break stuff.
A lot of stuff.
Maybe even a limb or two.
Well, why did
it have to be my limb?
Unfortunate.
It was unfortunate.
Click here.
Subscribe to
The Slow Mo Guys,
if you haven't already.
I have.
- Have you?
- No.